we're happy to say amanda gorman joins
us now there she is from los angeles
wearing her signature yellow hello
amanda gorman it's so good to see you
great to see you into your yellow i love
it yes i knew you were coming today
so i've heard you say that you you
wanted to find the words that the
world needed to hear and that you needed
to write we're very happy here at cbs we
are not late to the amanda gorman party
but do you feel like you've been
shot out of a rocket and what was it the
message you wanted the country
to get that day first i want to know
what this what this has been like for
you
after writing that poem and on the
national stage when people go who is
that
wow um rocket ship
is absolutely the correct word i feel
like i've been kind of
catapulted into this new chapter of my
life and it's
really just been so rewarding for me to
actually
watch and observe because um the effects
that i think that it's had
on poetry where i'm talking with other
writers and they're saying
wow you know my poetry book sales have
gone up after your inauguration speech
or
talking with teachers who are like
actually i'm going to bring back poetry
into the classroom that's huge for me
because it means the impact
lives on and it continues to change
people's ideas and beliefs about
all that literature can be yeah that's
nice i didn't know that part of the
story
what was what is the when you say i
wanted to come up with the
words that the world needed to hear and
i needed to write what does that mean
um well it means that for me as a writer
[Music]
often it's difficult to try to hold
yourself to coming
up with quote-unquote new ideas
for me i try to hold myself to the
standard which is how do i say
old feelings old ideas old sensations
in a new way so that all of a sudden
there exists a language to talk about
this pain to talk about this hope so for
me it's
kind of looking at the full expanse of
the human experience right now
particularly
as we battle covid as we battle racial
inequality and saying
what is the rhetoric that needs to be
born in order for us to have a way to
talk about this
both with honesty and with hope and we
need those words to be able to talk
about these issues amanda it's adriana
diaz we did a podcast together
about two years ago i don't know if you
remember you two remember i want to say
congratulations on the baby oh
thank you thank you amanda
so in 2018 you told me that you were
inspired by maya angelou who overcame
having a being mute as a child you grew
up with a speech impediment that makes
it hard to say certain words
but you said that you were able to turn
that what some people see as a weakness
into a strength how did you do that
lots of practice um for me um
growing up with a speech impediment
meant that i was always kind of
struggling to say
a certain set of words particularly
words that have r in them
and at first what that meant in my
poetry is i would actually erase
our words from my text so i wouldn't
have to say them
aloud but as i grew older and started to
lean into my voice and
having a speech impediment meant i kept
those words and started using poetry as
a speech pathology and so i learned a
lot through reciting poetry spoken word
and rap and the lyrics and taught myself
how to say these letters which for so
long
had been kind of my greatest weakness so
that it gave me the practice and the
strength to the point that i could do
something like an inaugural poem and so
i don't consider
having a speech impediment necessarily
as a disability but actually as a
strength it gave me my greatest
superpower which is my voice
that's a great way to look at it you
know another unique part of your
upbringing
amanda is well not only that your mother
is an english teacher but that
you had family meetings in your
household i believe from the time you
were three years old which is early on
the family meeting front
how did that help build your your love
of language and and your ability with
words
um today is actually my day to run the
family meeting so thank you for
reminding me of that
uh but it was always a great space that
my mom set up or
all the family members including the dog
who had to have her own translator
were called to the table and we were all
you know expected to come
discuss news our life in you know a very
kind of
civic and open and honest manner but
also every child was given the power to
run the meeting so my days are like
mondays and thursdays
and what that meant is even as a child
with the speech impediment
this meant that daily i had a platform
in which
my voice was heard and it's actually a
practice that i consider
um to continue today so i'll still be in
meetings
i'll still be on talk shows and i'm
still acting like that five-year-old
girl who was running the family meeting
and saying
actually we didn't get to hear about
your day actually i would love to
translate
for my dog who also has ideas at the
moment um whose food bowl is empty
and so it's kind of continuing that
practice of learning to pass the mic
even when you've been handed it well
listen i can't wait to see what happens
in 2036.
tony pointed this out i i love this you
know on the back your book there you are
standing in front of the presidential
seal
i'm thinking one of these days you will
be standing behind the presidential seal
and you'll be
madam president you're still you're
still planning that are you not
oh 100 all right amanda gorman
thank you so much it's so good to see
you good luck at the family meeting
today
something tells me you're going to kill
it bye everybody bye
as we mentioned the hill we climb goes
on sale tomorrow